[Music]
that's all
[Music]
that's how you look at me abroad so are
you doing that's a me were they then I
didn't ask him to do that do not do not
know I'm more worried about this this is
holy you don't [ __ ] with it
dead stop zooming on his eyes this is
against God idiot so guys what you're
looking at right now is the gaze of
miracles Manson okay you can fade out
that's close that was brought so the
gaze of miracles now this is a guy we've
spoken about before he is Croatian and
he has this great little scheme where
he'll he just stares at you it's called
he's called the gaze of miracles and
it's a healing session yeah it's a
healing session it heals cancer
heals you know heal your broken teeth
broken teeth yeah fathers if your dad
didn't love you it heals that yeah you
go back in time basically it fills you
with the love of 30 years of a father
and one gays know the the greatest thing
about it is that you can do it over
Skype oh yeah I mean we've we've goofed
on this guy before but he has actually
Skype livestream sessions and so I
thought it would be nice way to start
this episode with a little brat so gays
so I hope you felt the miracles the
power of miracles in the rest on to you
thanks for joining us today on the h3
podcast welcome to day
we have got the top of the week where we
just hang out and kick it and act like
you know it's all good even though it's
not it's just I know what that means
twitch and chill twitch and chill like
Netflix in this episode is sponsored by
seed cake god bless them more about that
later and of course all of our loyal
wonderful subscribers here on twitch if
you're subscribed on Twitch prime by
connecting your Amazon Prime account
which I know you all have you get a free
subscription they're not paying me I
just love the free money doesn't cost
you anything
oh you're Jill everybody loves free
money oh god you're trying to make money
from working you jus
everybody loves money sell out either
you're selling aren't you well you know
what [ __ ] it I'm both so smashed that
twitch frying button and if you want to
help out the show another way to help
out is to go on hop on over to iTunes
and leave a review right away yeah that
helps us you know helps us a lot
cuz say what up and say 8 you know just
just let go then we're out here gazing
with brats though so I've got a lot
planned for us to go over today it's
gonna be a lot of fun first of all I
just want to talk about what we've got
planned for Thursday we're moving the
main show from Friday the Thursday this
week only this week only this week
because we are going to Vegas with post
Malone on Friday mornings because we're
gonna go catch the big fight between
Conor McGregor Connor Murphy and Floyd
Mayweather we're actually not gonna be
there because I think it costs like
fifty thousand dollars for like a
nosebleed seat like I swear to god Dan
can you research what it costs for one
of those tickets so we're probably gonna
be in a bar somewhere but I'm definitely
gonna bet on it yeah so that the spread
right now was like twenty to one in
favor of Mayweather because it's a
boxing match and Conor is an MMA fighter
and so I think most people hold
correctly that he has absolutely no
chance of winning so that means if you
bet $100
on mate Danah are you trying to [ __ ]
ruin my life for what you're playing
[ __ ] what are you doing
Christ researching the fight in this
[ __ ] has autoplay do you have an answer
for you the cheap seats are only 500
bucks not that bad oh and what is it
really sold out though
what does it range up to that's frankly
I know that's still intermediary it
doesn't say what them I'm sure ringside
is like tens of thousands are at me
thank you voice of God mm-hmm I love it
voice of God just different sounds
answers on me this word we call them and
this word so anyway what was I talking
about
just that we're gonna be watching it
yeah we're so anyway if you bet $100 on
Mayweather and you win that means you
make like $5.00 hmm
so you have the bet wait that doesn't
make sense you have to bet 20 times
basically for every $20 you bet you get
$1 winning so if I bet $20 I win $1 so
you only that doesn't make sense your
honor lose money you win a little money
cuz he's so favored to win the fight
it's 20 to 1 odds that he's gonna win
I'm not sure the exact odds I'm just
telling you it's something like that so
it's like you do you bet $100 on
Mayweather and won 5 bucks because if
you bet $100 on McGregor and he wins
then you're making like frickin $2,000
so okay I see oh I see so you you're
winning 21 okay
22 1 yeah but you'll have like $21 it's
not like you're losing money no you
don't lose yeah you'll end up with 21
dollars but you're risking 24 the chance
of winning $1 what's the point right
yeah so I don't know I don't know if I
should bet on McGregor for the big four
that like double green you know maybe
I'll hedge my bet maybe I'll play both
sides anyway I'm excited is going
be fun we're gonna go get smashed play
some black checks gonna be a lot of fun
then on Thursday you guys remember
Skippy the 34 year old virgin it was a
last video on h3 so I've been in talking
with him I've been trying to figure out
how can we include him in the show and I
think we've got the perfect idea so you
guys all remember Rian Johnson is right
that the incredible really gifted pickup
artist and rapper he's a mean he's a
Renaissance man he's a rapper he's a
pickup artist he's he started his own
religion yeah he's he owns a cult
parently any [ __ ] like crazy gonna get
me it's also just a businessman and an
author anyway I said you're making fun
of them but he's God anyway so we're
gonna get them both on the phone
together because I want Ryan John CMAs
to coach Skippy on how to get a girl and
then eventually in the following week I
want to bring them both down to LA and
get them together on the street picking
up girls together picking up hot
stripper [ __ ] at Whole Foods in the
words of Ryan Jones Miss M which is
something we've done together so that's
my and then eventually you guys well I
don't know if I want to give away the
big twist but the goal is to get Skippy
late essentially here at the h3 podcast
we believe in the advancement of all
humanity all social you know pursuits
many have called a social justice
warriors and I think many will after
this because my social justice is
getting Skippy like that's a horrible
idea
no it's a great idea you're all you're
all it's a horrible idea
I'd watch I though just to be clear
we're not they're not coming here this
isn't gonna be a call well the first
one's gonna be a call then they're
coming down here and I swear to you now
Skippy's getting laid that's my goal oh
I don't care if you think that's
horrible it's gonna be entertaining and
that's why we're doing it who oh who
suffers Skippy will the girl the girl
suffers but she's gonna do it willingly
I'm not gonna dumb to rape somebody
clearly there's consent involved if you
don't think that's gonna be entertaining
then you're lying to yourself did Ryan
confirm though mm-hmm it's not even
comfort haven't heard from Ryan but
he'll say yes anyway and then that that
moves me on to my next comment I've been
meaning to tell you talked to you about
this Gila I've lost all respect for you
sorry it's true Danny are you laughing
out there I've lost all respect for you
as well and myself I've lost all respect
for myself
hashtag new meme alert man I I don't
know what's up with this podcast but it
brings out like in terms of our fans or
the people who comment and participate
oh god it's like I've seen this comment
like a thousand times since we started
doing the podcast regulates that I've
lost all respect for you I remember the
context of one of them was like um I was
talking about the AI stuff in the last
top of the week and one of the top
comments like on somewhere I remember
where was Ethan needs to do more
research on this and frankly I've lost
all respect for him that's it after
three years of hanging out and doing
this [ __ ] together that's what it was
this is no way you tell like a rapist or
pedophile I lost more respect for you I
spent what about me because apparently
they thought I was using Internet
Explorer on my laptop that's a joke
no but they were kind of serious at the
same time stuff like like how could you
using lost oh well this is Betty but I
wasn't even using it was an accident
okay
there was this other one like yeah just
basically when you're talking for three
hours and you get something a little bit
wrong that you you watch for three hours
and you're like man I disagree with that
I need to go in the comments right I've
lost all respect for Ethan like dude
we've been through [ __ ] together
that's it I swear to god I've seen that
so many times or like last on the
interview with Jake Paul Ethan was too
nice to Jake I've lost all respect for
him or Ethan was
to Harsanyi all respect for him oh wow
Ethan talked about face banks listened
talked with that about I've lost all
respect for him
Ethan Ethan about I've lost all respect
all respect it's all gone all the
respect is gone
so [ __ ] like can we reserve that
saying for something a little more
serious Simon this is a John Oliver joke
Simon you raped my little brother I've
lost all respect for you that's an
appropriate time to use that not you
made some factual some so some of your
research wasn't wasn't performed that
the best it could I've lost all respect
for you
[Laughter]
yeah I'm triggered so what that's just
crazy like doing this podcast it exposes
your self yeah when you make a h3 video
you're editing it down perfectly
representing yourself into a ten minute
clip yeah you can choose right you say
something in a few different ways you
can choose the best way you said it
right yeah daddy thing is just like so
it's such a big part of it and you know
what you're saying you're talking about
something but here on the podcast you
talk for three hours it's live it's
unedited so basically it's just so much
more raw and you're so much more exposed
to the judgment of those people watching
and it's like people just [ __ ] lose
all respect to you yeah I mean that's
that's it but it's it's hard on me and
heal emotionally too because we're
opening ourselves up in a way that we
never had that's why I like the putt cuz
because it's challenging it makes me
uncomfortable but on the other hand you
know I I am it's an interesting
experience yeah frankly I lost all
respect for myself sheesh but I know
that there's people out there who enjoy
it so thank you to you guys where we're
working hard to make it better every
week like it's super important to me I
am I have really high goals and dreams
for what this show here can become and I
hope that you guys see the improvement
we're working really hard to to bring
that to you and I mean we're gonna get
skip
dick what if that's not the pinnacle I
don't know what it oh that's
inappropriate I've lost all respect just
watch it's gonna be great it's
definitely making my skin thicker though
being on YouTube making YouTube videos
makes your skin thick to one degree but
doing this you're like [ __ ] Colossus
from the x-men but you're already thick
[Laughter]
I'm thick but I am still very sensitive
all right let's move it on what the [ __ ]
else I got to talk about talked with
Ethan and Moe Bradbury we're gonna
actually at long last get them in here I
don't know I'm a date yet but I'm up
[Music]
we're gonna get them in here and that's
good I just realized if they come here
we need to set up a red carpet for them
is that a meme no we need a red carpet
for them but is that just is that
reference or something or no it's like
we need Dan doing handheld one of these
cameras with them yeah we should have
like 20 extras clapping just bring fans
in you clap for them and then dance on
the sand board spamming slamming so
anyway but you know with all that
complaining I have I do have to say that
I was actually looking forward to
Tuesday this weekend mm-hm which is a
really cool good sign
yeah usually I don't look forward to
making videos cuz it's like I don't know
I just don't look forward to it I kind
of dread it honestly because it's see
much or stressful yeah but this I was
actually looking forward to doing so I
think that's a good sign found out we
were nominated for a Streamy award in
comedy but I'm a little confused
it's streamys one of the ones where you
have to beg your fans to vote for you
well the real question is is there an
award show where you don't for like the
web stuff not I mean yeah that is yeah
does it exist
I don't know because I know there's
these award show
like last year fouseytube like swept it
and it's like all it is is just a
competition to see who can beg their
fans the most shamelessly to go vote for
them 20 times and then if the company
was giving out the award is just like
has like pop ups and all the spammy ads
on their website this is a total scheme
to market the award company I don't know
if the streamys does that dan can you
research that without playing what a
commercial what is that oh Sh award show
for like web stuff streamys and the
shorties the shorties yeah I think they
they're the same no well if streamys
doesn't do it so by like a group a
secret group that's legit mm-hmm but the
voting thing really takes like really
rubs me wrong it's just such a scheme
you know nice trying to see if anyone in
the chat knows about it I submit I just
looked it up and it looks like it's
completely vote based even the
nominations which I guess means some of
your fans wait really
the nominations are vote based on their
website there's like a place where you
can submit nominations it looks like hmm
and it's complete so people can go vote
for us for comedy so that's such a
scheme because I looked online and it
said though it said it was done by a
group of people that's I feel like all
this internet award shows they're all
they all do the same thing they just
rely on you doing your own marketing for
them exactly
whoever can promote our company the most
well we know a meaningless award yeah
thanks for making us a hundred thousand
dollars plus and advertising and earlier
brand the things that everyone wants to
win an award so it's like I'm not
blaming anyone for yes going along with
it you know
no but it's a it's a little scheme yeah
- total scheme so anyway shout out to
the [ __ ] shorties that's really don't
go there screaming louder
all right I got a video for you guys to
watch Jordan's first pitch some of you
guys may have seen this if you have or
haven't it's definitely washing I mean
this is just one of my favorite videos
to come out of this whole year so you
know about the first pitch right EULA
mmm
so whenever you open a baseball game you
have someone of note or a public figure
or okay you're talking about me I know I
know come and throw the first pitch to
open the game right so in this in this
case they had this guy Jordan don't know
who he is but he's someone very
important throw the first pitch
spontaneously made is mad dash around
the bases running for the first time
under his own power
after years of treatment at the Jimmy
Fund now a 17 year old right-handed
pitcher at Barnstable high school on
Cape Cod welcome back Jordan I played
football so this kid is an inspiration I
guess he had some kind of surgery and he
ran for himself around the field what an
inspiration so he's back to the first
pitch
[Music]
get aboard walk out to the field
everyone's lined up pay their respects
to this God Jordan he's got to speak
into the red carpet going down one he
looks confident he looks cool a chewing
gum
he's a total badass this guy's thrown a
couple balls in this time he looks like
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're listening to this through a
really juicy curve ball that way to the
right side of the catcher and hit some
cameraman in the nuts no laughter where
you guys at it's a [ __ ] classic nut
shot give me a break here this is gold
tough crowd huh man after our show
yesterday after the Jake Paul show we
had a really traumatic experience
[ __ ] we're moving to a new house and
I called LA power and electric to change
our address mm-hmm to cancel the service
at our old house and to move into our
new house and I gave them in September
the date when we move out
edie we came back after the the Jake
Paul podcast and there was no power and
no water who was completely shut down
they came a month early to our house
when nobody was
and they did a hard shutoff on all of
our services and just to give you a
little perspective we just had our trash
cans put out on the street because that
was the day that they like empty them
mm-hmm so I just before walking into the
house we both just pulled the trash cans
back to their spot so we just touched
the trash cans which are disgusting and
was just waiting to wash our hands as
soon as we get into the house
why walked in I tried to soak my hands
and then there's no water it got to be
one of the worst feelings in the world
so I call them up I don't know what's
with government workers but they are all
so worthless I call them up I'm like
yell you guys turned off my frickin
power and everything my gas my power my
water a month early well thank you for
calling us mr. Klein I understand you're
having a little bit of emergency let me
ask a like this to her supervisor or no
she talks to her supervisor she's like
my supervisor is reviewing the call to
see if it was our mistake of yours yeah
to see if you said September or August
I'm like all right I mean that's fine
cuz I do want to know if I said it right
or not but in the other hand it's like
are you knock are you just not gonna
help me if it wasn't my fault yeah she's
gonna make me sit here with no
electricity and water which century yes
yes yeah they're like if it's not our
fault we can't get to you for like a
week I'm like thanks dude I'm glad I'm
paying my [ __ ] taxes let's come turn
my [ __ ] on my human being I've got needs
I just took a [ __ ] might old I get flush
it
dude that beads so she goes she puts me
on hold for like 20 minutes her managers
listening to the call she comes back she
says hi my manager just listened to the
call and you did in fact say August we
listened to it you said August I was
like no I couldn't believe it he says no
way let me talk to your supervisor and
let me hear that tape well mister
she clearly heard August and that's I'm
afraid that's all I can do for you so so
Ethan said okay fine but please send me
a copy of that tape I want to hear it
for myself right and then she was like
okay you know I will listen to it again
I'm insisting that they send me that the
copy of the conversation so meanwhile
when I keep pushing she's like you know
what you know what my manager she's
actually still listening to the call
yeah I'm like okay so he puts me back on
hold she comes back five minutes later
and she's like you know what the
recording was really low so she couldn't
hear it very well but we've actually you
did say September so it's an art mistake
and meanwhile Neal is looking at me like
you [ __ ] up and I'm starting in my own
head like did I [ __ ] up because Nathan
was on the phone with them and so well
this lazy [ __ ] did they even listen to
the call oh it was low
you did say September that doesn't make
any sense
after you insist on getting a copy yeah
you [ __ ] kidding me
so so then anyway I had to I had to wait
for them for three hours it was already
dark so I just set in our car because
Ethan had to go what we were supposed to
go to a meeting together yeah but
they're like I can only do it now and
you have to be there oh this is the next
part the person I'm talking to the lady
was like my supervisor was listening the
tape I was like do we have to be there
she's like no as long as there's access
were like great so we start heading out
and then someone else calls me to
confirm the appointment and she's like
somebody has to be there I was like what
do you guys talk to each other so they
have to go back drop off ela who sits in
the dark in our driveway yeah for three
hours and a brie is just sitting in the
darkness what are you doing there I was
just I'm and my phone battery was dying
yeah all great never washed my hands she
survived by the way she never washed her
hands [ __ ] isn't have Ebola you
survived so that was a little drama we
had these
the people running are our world at
least they did fix it at the end they
did fix it in then we did have power oh
man oh man I'm telling you I'm not
saying no no I was right it was gonna be
a whole weekend like that cuz they all
so I was right before the week yeah I
was just about to incite domestic
terrorism but they lent a joking matter
but I think probably not the best
climate to make those jokes just imagine
I had made a joke about an domestic
terror against government I like that
Felix PewDiePie
yeah just said that - because before it
was like I'm just making jokes about you
know Nazi stuff but I'm obviously I'm
not in Nazi but it seems like now you in
this climate you chose jokes like don't
you know what it loved me
Felix made this video where he's like
okay I'm gonna finally do this even
though it's stupid
I'm denouncing these people mm-hm and
guess guess what YouTube trended that
video yeah of all the videos he's made
in the past six months since that whole
should happen there like this is all
algorithmic the trending we're gonna
trend this video I got more to say about
that later but I do have an important
story to tell actually you know what but
we can talk about the trending now cuz I
was just gonna say whenever you ask
YouTube how do they choose what goes on
trending they say it's just an algorithm
and it depends on how much the video was
shared across the internet like if it
was shared on some other sites right but
then you see videos trending that no
there's no way that they were shirt
anywhere NBC News Jeff Dunham talks
about is why peanut well if they won't
trend up a superwoman this new video
with 200 views is trending again not
even inherit you really see like you
really see some dumb ones there shut up
over there now the trending list is such
[ __ ] so anyway the thing is that our
podcast with Jake Paul was basically
let's see here
oh my god actually we're worried
so we are trending and well you know
I'll get to that in a sec we're skipping
ahead I've got this all planned out okay
was the first thing I wanted to do
before we get into that because I want
to talk about that and I want to talk
about all the content ID frickin bull
crap we went through too but there's
something really important we need to
before that which is neighbors have a
broom fight this dude is holding a broom
I know this lady's thing she's got a can
of spray paint and she's tagging up his
property this dude upstairs is filming
she's got like a white spray paint she's
tagging up his Bush so why you was
upstairs filming she's tagging I was BBQ
this guy gives chase and after with this
every time she tags in loud the hold on
this is building up something special
don't discern I'm telling you this [ __ ]
pays off so now she's now she's walking
out with the broom handle and you know
shits about to go down stop what's the
new Star Wars come out the last Jedi
this is that this is a official preview
look at this show off dude this is like
an old western showdown so she's walking
out with spray paint one hand and the
mop and another one and homies coming
out with this broom now to confront her
she's got our grinder back like a badass
she's ready to go Shogun on her
this is [ __ ] enter the 21 chamber some
ninja [ __ ] pay off and build up - that
was so good when she comes like walking
out with their own broom handle and you
realize you have a good old-fashioned
like samurai battle watch this
[Music]
you know I love the devolution it's such
a great pace story of good and evil as
soon as you walk down with that room so
good and she's oh man all right let's
move it on so anyway let's get serious
what the [ __ ] were you talking about oh
yeah I have a really serious story this
is really serious I'm not kidding like I
know we joke here I know like you come
here to have fun and laugh and forget
about your troubles but this one's kind
of important so just you know listen up
what you got
so the other day right before Jake Paul
I went in the bathroom take his [ __ ]
okay
so what some of us have heard some of
you may have heard this story but I
didn't say it officially on the podcast
I said it immediately after I came back
but I think it's important to share with
the world at large I was taking a [ __ ]
right before I don't know what's with my
body I've heard people saying that they
never [ __ ] at work because their body's
like oh I need to be in my natural
habitat and I love that as a philosophy
but every time I step foot in the office
I'm ready to [ __ ] my pants
Hayden two-minute like 45 seconds before
that launch clock was about to hit I was
walking in with a little toilet paper
hanging out my underwear anyway I mean
they're taking a [ __ ] and these two
white collar businessman walking talking
amongst themselves talking about golf
they sound like really rich to do guys
right ones at the urinal one hits the
stall right next to him and he starts
blasting ass like sometimes you take a
[ __ ] it comes out like silently
delicately it gets cups into the water
and it's like a perfect 10 at at an
Olympic dive no splash sometimes you
[ __ ] squirt mic and this guy was
squirting right like sometimes you
squirt so bad that [ __ ] gets on your
butt cheeks not just your [ __ ] but
your butt cheeks okay okay that was I'm
just trying to illustrate the the
severity of the [ __ ] he was having so he
walks in and
eally drops trou blasts their can their
conversation doesn't miss a beat
once on the urinal ones on the [ __ ]
doesn't miss a beat they keep talking
about golf his friend at the urinal
finishes goes to the sink to wash his
hands
the friend on the [ __ ] who was
blasting else finishes at the same time
he doesn't reach for toilet paper he I
swear to god it was like a thirty
seconds and then he he lifts back up his
trousers
that is I'm unbelievable didn't wipe
didn't wipe no no he didn't reach for
one single square mm-hmm exits the stall
and they leave the bathroom together I
don't even think he washed his hands and
that the weird part is like if you're a
weirdo and you don't wipe your ass why
would you do it why would you make your
friend an accomplice to that right I
have never seen anything like that
oh Sh act I was in there like I was in
there just absolutely losing my mind you
know and you're still disturbed by it
well I had yes the the Tuesday episode
is really more like therapy then you
guys get it out and frankly I lost all
respect for those guys oh I know what
did they do in the building cuz he
didn't wash his hands or wipe the worst
part yeah hmm he's probably a
chiropractor but that's what I was
wondering like how dude dude [ __ ] their
pants how do they get streak marks and I
guess there's people out there who just
straight up and don't wipe then he gives
us dirty whites - his wife is like
here's honey there's a fire shit-stained
of dirty whites
I didn't think those people existed I
don't know that's why the bathrooms so
[ __ ] cool is it because when you're
in a stall and when I'm in there I'm
quiet nobody knows I'm there I'm like a
[ __ ] ghost mm-hmm you know and you
get this you see people in a very
intimate setting or like you're like oh
damn what's going on in here it's like a
I feel like you could do and see that
way I tried don't do this faster than I
can and leave but you never you don't
really
to see people and the [ __ ] like it's
a very private mm-hmm and you're doing
in a public place I feel like if you're
a sociologist you could set up a really
profound experiment there I think Joey
salads could set up a really profound I
think he has actually there's this more
pranks that pranksters do that I
actually think is funny and horrible a
you know assuming that it's not set up
they do it where they'll going to stall
next to so much [ __ ] and then like
wipe Nutella on their shoes that they'll
be like hey do you can do you have extra
toilet paper oh yeah and they hand the
role under words and they wipe Nutella
on their hand as they grab the roll
it's got to be set up though it's gotta
be yeah but I have seen that or they are
the worst ones that will actually wipe
it on their shoes right who did that we
saw that some some piece-of-shit
monsters YouTube pranksters which is why
it has to be set up there's nothing so
yeah I think so
I'd like to think so here's something
that women don't go through that guys do
go through sometimes because I wear
sandals a lot I'll stand next to a guy a
urinal Oh God [ __ ] urine splashes on
my [ __ ] feet dude that you I'm
telling you it happens and it's
horrifying I'm just giving you the
realities of what life is out there EULA
but I'm sure it's weird [ __ ] goes on the
women's bathroom no really for like what
periods well yeah but what like
sometimes I'll walk into like in college
we had a co-ed bathroom and I remember
sometimes there would be like the
remnants of a period in the toilet and
like there's a blood like pool of red
blood at the bottom cuz it's heavier
than water I guess but it's not on your
feet yeah exactly that's what I mean
there's no like interaction no that's
that's pretty much as bad as it gets it
could be really messy sometimes in the
women's bathroom during the like you
like the I [ __ ] some of it it's more
messy than the men's bathroom mm-hmm but
there's no interaction no period blood
squirted on your
you know yeah that sounds a lot worse
somehow that's upward now that's
probably the worst thing is when another
dudes urine splash on my feet it's just
like dude wow like you can't blame them
either that's the thing they're not
[ __ ] up it's a shitty bathroom I'm
telling you man this is therapy this is
good for me
you guys are incidental to this so
anyway what else we got oh you guys I'm
sure you all heard about the solar
eclipse yeah then whatever eclipse
whatever it was actually really cool we
woke up that morning it was yesterday
right Yeah right right right whatever
yeah yeah it was a it was this week it
was yesterday optional let's say it was
yesterday
and I woke up I didn't see the Eclipse
cuz I didn't have the space goggles that
apparently sold out by the way can we
observe can we just acknowledge how
those space goggle people made a killing
made a billion dollars from those space
goggles probably cost like five cents to
make that [ __ ] they're sold out in the
whole country you can't buy space
goggles so I wasn't able to actually
view it but the lighting was really
eerie and spooky like it was just super
unnatural feeling yeah it was weird like
it was it was like normal but weird I
don't know how to it was just dark but
it felt dust like dusty and murky but
there was a clear I'm dark at the same
time but here somebody did actually get
a video because this is in LA so we had
about a 70% to a total eclipse but
here's a video I found of somebody who
had a total eclipse um and it was really
cool to watch really awesome and very
fascinating more fascinating than
anything really fascinating even all the
podcast is Ethan saying fascinating I've
lost all respect for that sounds like a
that sounds like it
it sounds like a joke but I swear to God
that was an ironic comment I saw alright
so is there sound in this I guess
there's no sound but anyway you can see
here I'm showing a video of the moment
that it becomes a total eclipse I'm not
sure this for somewhere in the path
where it's probably close to 100%
here you go it's just turning in tonight
it's so bizarre dan can you play the
brought some music look at this it's so
cool so cool
it's just you can see all that looks so
badass
seriously it's just straight-up
nighttime the the lights are on on the
street
it looks like it's 8:00 a p.m. really
cool and that's as dope there's this one
picture that came out of the Eclipse
this picture is unreal look at this you
see the [ __ ] it's a plane
driving right as the total eclipse is
about to occur perfectly geometric it
looks like a sword yeah that's I thought
I didn't know what I was looking at I
saw him reddit the guy who took it was
by sheer accident apparently but that's
got to be one of the coolest pictures
ever taken if we're all if we all perish
and I wish I saw it yeah that does look
pretty awesome I don't think it looks
quite like that these are like gum
special telescopes and some but if we
perish you know this is pretty cool
we got to observe that what else we got
as a little traumatic there's a little
[ __ ] dramatic how do I remove this I
got it what else I got a bunch of really
cool oh yeah this is another thing this
is so
cool about total solar eclipses if you
guys have seen this like basically if
you look at shadows of a tree during the
total eclipse what you're seeing is a
projection of the eclipse and the
concept behind it is really cool because
essentially right gets so small then
it's like it's kind of like a camera
effect is that what it is
well what it's kind of exhibiting is
that you just when you look at a wall
during a normal son it's just flooded
with light it's just one consistent
light but it actually consists of a ton
of light beams individual light beams
and so this is what it's showing you can
actually now see the individual light
beams with the Eclipse here because it's
broken the light is broken in half I
didn't really understand that's it's so
we're such so trippy mad you mean like a
Native American and seeing this [ __ ]
like no wonder they have all these
superstitious beliefs and so it's
basically I've learned about it in the
art school it's kind of like what
happens inside a camera basically right
it's a when you close the shutter right
or the iris you can do don't like in
your house for example if you in a room
and you make it all dark and on a window
like cover it so it's completely dark
but leave one tiny hole you'll get on if
you have like a window and like a wall
across from it if you leave just a tiny
hole in the window on the wall you'll
get a reflection of the street and it's
upside down right ya can try it at home
it's so cool and that's how the classic
painters used to paint right yeah they
would cheat they would get a reflection
do a little hole in the wall and and
trace over it yeah [ __ ] cheaters
Leonardo DiCaprio art and I'll end it
there I'll Chuck I'll stop trying to
sound smart after that one here's
another picture this is middle of the
day
that is the moon right in the middle of
the Sun in the middle of the day and
it's pitch black
yeah it's really cool anyway you guys
know how it works you guys know how that
[ __ ] works
so but something that I did find funny
was that Neil smoked deGrasse Tyson made
it sweet a couple days ago
he's like told ya I don't know cuz there
was like a huge mania like it was a
frenzy it's almost annoying like every
person I ran into on the street was like
are you gonna watch the solar eclipse
like no I'm not I'm here you know I get
to do it's just like I wish I traveled
somewhere but you see are you trying are
you are you traveling to Ohio mm-hmm
well apparently in these places the path
of the total solar eclipse there was
like millions of people
yeah well anyway Neil the Neil smoked
deGrasse Tyson said total solar eclipse
occurs somewhere on earth every two
years so just calm yourself when people
tell you they're rare mm-hmm so I guess
it's not that big of a deal although
just to explain what like they occur
somewhere on earth so you're not flying
to Indonesia yeah in two years or
wherever it's gonna be next or the
middle of the Pacific it so happens I
think the last one that occurred over
the United States was 40 years ago so
why don't you back the [ __ ] off and not
be such a wet towel I love the solar
eclipse I'm an eclipse boy I like that
too it
you like that tweet you would you guys
are professional haters anyway he does
have a point just a little just a little
perspective what else oh let's not let's
think seeking SeatGeek really fast thank
you to our sponsor what happened oh my
computer just restarted that's nice man
this thing's a piece of crap can you
hear me is everything all right Dan yeah
you're good okay
yeah the computers okay thank you so
much to our sponsor today seat geek seat
geek is an app that aggregates tickets
to live events from all over the web to
make buying simple
they put a zero hundred score on each
ticket to let you know if you're getting
a good deal or a bad deal the good ones
are green and the bad ones are red
here's my favorite part if you order a
seat the app basically lets you see the
view from your seat if you get a Dodgers
ticket or a sporting event you can
actually get the view from that seat and
understand exactly where you're sitting
and see a stadium so you know if it's a
good or bad seat and let me tell you
what else okay if you head on over to
seat geek and use code they don't have a
custom URL there's a link in the
description if you use code h3h3 you get
$20 off your first order there's a link
in the description dan you should be
spamming a tube for twitch it's not a I
mean basically you just get the app you
download the app use CODIS yeah it's not
a condom I'm actually a huge fan of
ckick because there's so many shady
predatory ticket agents out there yeah
they're like oh you uh the tickets are
$10 but the service fee is a thousand
god I hate taking math ticket companies
but ckick is one of the good ones so if
you are in the market to hit up and
event anything they've got everything
there and you want to support the show
head on over to seat geek and use code
h3h3 click the link in the description
to help support the show and get
yourself some great tickets with $20 off
your first order
thank you to ckick alright my computer
flippin shrekt I was about to talk about
the Content ID [ __ ] on the Jake Paul
episode mm-hmm that was such a nightmare
actually I need to get water I can't
take a break those I'm not logged in my
computer died what does that matter I
need water
essentially is what I'm saying you are
so you are
are you logged in uh and then is lawyer
you logged in so just you have to do
over a little bit of frankensteining
here but I'll just say we will be back
NH well do we even need that for the
Youtube version this isn't because
you're there's no break it's just like a
cut
no yeah we don't need it just say to the
people watching right now I think they
know about the people watching I'm gonna
take a short break to get some water I
think I'm I'm back
alright st. and just hang back here one
sec guys why does my computer die if I
lift it a little bit I think I'm gonna
call that a design flaw this isn't the
first time all right we'll be back in a
short two minutes guys stay tuned we are
got more spicy hot schmutz on the way
[Music]
oh yeah let me hear you best matzo let
me hear you to proclaim the name of
bronze oh there was only one case that
lost all respect for you're not gonna
give me a brats oh [ __ ] you guys not
alright alright soon pull it out
mm-hm we've got enough Kaazing hope you
guys are feeling reinvigorated after
that gaze and I am ready to jump right
in so where were we
basically yeah so we did the Jake Paul
episode last last week I think I went
really well I was happy with the way it
went the amount of complaining is is
crazy like I don't know what people
people are complaining that I'm going to
easy on him and that they've lost all
respect for him me emphasize on all
respect loss all respect respect but the
thing is do you guys really want like me
just to come in here and berate him I
mean this is a place to have an actual
conversation my goal here when I have a
guest like Jake Paul is to give you an
insight to what kind of person he
actually is and he does that by
answering questions right yeah and
sometimes like when with the post Malone
thing he kind of gives me a [ __ ]
answer and that's when I can move on
them to make some kind of confrontation
right but the whole point is to have a
mature conversation if you're if you're
here for any other reason then I've lost
all respect for you frankly I mean it's
just we're all people
you know we can't it's not like he's
just an enemy and we're just gonna be
mean to him right obviously we disagree
with a lot of stuff he does and the way
we creates his content but that doesn't
mean you know this is a war that he's
gonna walk into he's still person and I
think that's the most interesting thing
me when we have a guest like that what
excites me is to humanize this person
for better or worse right like if
they're full of [ __ ] I will call them on
it but I want to humanize them I want
them to see I want you to see them as a
person because they are and that's
interesting mm-hmm I think that's
interesting and that's not even the main
point the mayor mean that is the main
point but other things to consider is if
we bring every guest here that we
disagree with and just berate them who's
gonna want to ever come on our show yeah
it's ridiculous but that's anyway so we
we upload that and usually we we post
the vaad to YouTube like a day later or
two days later and what happened because
we have to do some post-production on it
we have to export it we have to upload
it to YouTube what happens is that
people on Twitch are able to rip clips
from our live stream and post it on
YouTube first and I've never went
through such a cancer like YouTube is so
[ __ ] oh my god so one dude like there
was like a thousand bootleg clips with
the tons of use arranging from you know
three minutes up to the whole of the
whole two hours one of them was like a
six minute clip of us talking about him
daxing post Malone and that video was
uploaded well before our official one
and it received like four million views
in 24 hours and I wrote to you there's
like a friggin sirens outside
I wrote to YouTube basically immediately
when I noticed it and I said please
remove this video and some fringing on
my copyright it was just a ripoff there
was nothing added so obviously it was a
copyright violation competing with our
own video and they respond after 10
hours this video already has 10 million
views and they says we need more
information from you proving this is
your video that's 10 hours in it's
already has 4 million views it's
trending YouTube even trended this video
in like where was it Canada where in
some country they actually trended this
ripped off clip
and I spoke to after like 20 hours we
finally got it removed but I like this
I'm emailing them from the official HTTP
podcast email and they need more
information from me to prove it's my
clip I says okay so this guy ripped off
three million views he's probably made
three to five thousand dollars from that
like what can we do about that and my
rep says this well the only way you can
get that is to ask him ask the guy who
ripped it off nicely look are you
[ __ ] kidding me it's interesting to
get the perspective of both sides
because I've always been on the side of
like abusers copyright holders but now
to be on the side of a copyright holder
who's being [ __ ] over by somebody is
really interesting the only way you can
get your money back from this theft it's
that easy to scam on YouTube yep that's
why there's so many people who do it
it's crazy
so our video wasn't on YouTube and then
algorithmically YouTube thinks that this
pirated clip is the original one of the
podcast because arson isn't up there yet
so they think ours is a derivative of
the one that that guy ripped off from us
so it's getting promoted it's being
suggested it's being on the homepage and
all that [ __ ] that our media actually
isn't getting because it's considered a
derivative it took 12 hours to get it
removed and we don't get any of that
money back it was so uh and it was so
frustrating I was just really shocked
every time we talked to people at
YouTube they all know I still know what
we do they're all fans right they always
say oh we're fans but then it's like do
you guys see that there's a re-up load
of our show being trended right now and
getting four million views is nobody
seeing it I don't understand I love that
the reupload gets trended and ours of
course is nowhere well that's not quite
true actually
so we have this theory that our our pot
are not just our podcasts our whole
brand is completely banned from trending
the last time we were trended was
basically before the humongous that
whole story broke and I swear to God I
have a conspiracy theory that our
channel
got on the [ __ ] list because of our
stance to defend humongous and we got
marked as like a hate channel mm-hmm or
a drama channel or something like that
and we got we got totally [ __ ] where
our channel wasn't showing up on the
homepage it wasn't showing up and
related wasn't showing up in the sidebar
and recently I did speak with some of
that YouTube who seems to have resolved
that for us but I think we're banned
from trending because it wasn't before
then and nothing of ours so let me put
this in perspective for you the podcast
was number one trending in Canada and
this is a pattern what the [ __ ] is this
screenshot that is so worthless what is
this that is not related to anything
what the hell was that hold on maybe
this one's it yeah here you go
so I see this all the time our videos
trending in Canada Australia the UK but
never in the United States it's been at
least a year yeah we haven't been on the
trending in the US so this was the
podcast was trending number one in
Canada it was trending in Iceland
it was trending in Sweden these are all
screenshots people sent us it's trending
in Latvia it was trending in Germany
this podcast but I don't know I'm so
over you too man there's so many
problems and I and I really think that
the management of YouTube is just is run
by ideological [ __ ] zealots like this
should be a democratic platform based on
people what and wants to be seen as
shown I mean they own the company they
have the right to do ever they want but
they're there it's tricky about it the
operating shadow the trending page is
just at least like yeah be transparent
about what's happening there
they can't mean you know why because the
same thing with the Google memo because
what they're doing is probably illegal
or at best very unscrupulous mm-hmm so
they can't they can't be upfront about
it like most of the people will work
there actually don't know what's at
what's really happening
because everyone you would ask they'll
say the same answer like oh it's just
it's based on an algorithm based on how
much a video was shared my friends they
all play every casing nice that video is
trending yeah there's every single KC
nice that video has ever made is
trending it's always the same people
you'll only see the same people there
they choose really marketable people
because they always give me the same
response about trending it doesn't get
you that many views or subscribers so
who so what you know don't worry about
it that's what they always tell us but
they mark it they put the marketable
people there right because the people
who aren't trying to get noticed by
brands and companies and basically
become the face of YouTube which has a
lot of perks beyond being subscribers or
views yeah you always see the same
people like Liza I'm not first of all
I'm not making any value judgement about
these people no I think they're all
talented people these are the people
it's about how the trending page is
being run yeah you see Liza Koshi you
see Casey nice that is the most obscene
like you literally see every video there
is shameless it's been going on for
years it's gotten to the point where you
go to his comments and they're all like
why is Casey on trending again or why is
he being suggested to me I've never
watched one of his videos you see the
vlogbrothers like they'll show up there
was like a hundred thousand views and
I'm like what a superwoman you see the
same people there it's it's it's
annoying I really want to find a way to
be independent of YouTube it's getting
frustrating it's like you have this
shadowy master who beholds their fate in
your hand daily they control whether you
you know are successful or not
pretty much it's not democratic at all
anyway let me let me just segue into my
next point here's as smoothly as
possible and watch eggs [ __ ] death
Ninja Warrior
to get disqualified immediately but he's
death so he can't hear the whistles and
the and everyone telling him that he
failed this is some great age range my
friend this is something straight out of
a sketch comedy show and I feel my heart
breaks for this guy but it is really
special to watch my stepson Josh so Josh
will
like pull no when the buzzer sounds to
start his run what an inspirational blog
what an inspiration there you go there's
the signal he's underwater his foot
touch the water so he's disqualified but
he can't hear the buzzer everybody's
saying that he's out is this tragic or
what someone had to climb up the monkey
bars and be like yo dude you're
disqualified and the dude's deaf so he
can't understand what it's saying so
he's looking around at his son who signs
he's like what is he saying I don't know
why it's trying to get its attention now
because something they do climb that the
monkey bars say you're disqualified so
now his son signalling and he's like hey
you're you know God let them forget out
there and trying he'll be better next
year and he's gonna kill it but this
whole situation is just so so amazing I
was then and I'm funny I do a deaf Ninja
Warrior being immediately disqualified
and can't hear it's like oh my god it's
a cartoon anyway I love this format I
get into deep on something serious and
I'm like Ariela watch this [ __ ] crap
clearly right up all right so now I got
to make a little correction again once
again going back to the Jake Paul
episode I don't know if I like this
format really why we get them finished
talking about one and topic and then
move on were we not done this is before
I talked about Jake ball this is the
face this is the face big thing it's
very dense
you got to break it up I feel like I
step into your mind with the ADH three
step into the mind of man yes I've lost
all respect for myself we should rename
this podcast from h3 podcast I've lost
all respect for you the h3 podcast it's
I have a method it's not 8 is this great
you got some good so then you get real
worried the get real face get real we're
talking about a Boeing 3 it's not about
J penguins already let me get into it
it's not about Jay Paul in the jig Paul
episode he accused phase banks which we
spoke about briefly during that episode
of like putting his assistant in a
headlock and bruising her neck yeah it
was a huge allegation and a lot and when
we did that show phase hadn't made any
statements about it but he made a
response video that turned into this
huge internet drama which by the way you
can acute like that's kind of a serious
accusation yeah I don't think at the
time I expressed in a position where
were the other if you did think that I
was supporting Jake that wasn't my
intention at all I was merely just
asking about it I'm not taking any sons
I'm not taking phase Bank side here but
I just think it's fair to represent his
counter-argument since we gave Jake's
and that's just one side of the story
right so phase bank's basically says man
this is a well he's denying everything
he's dead denying everything and the one
thing that kind of makes me you know
makes me look the whole thing is so
weird
like this is serious stuff this isn't
beef we can't be joking about like
choking women so phase apparently went
to the nightclub or face banks went to
the nightclub and got the security
footage and on the security footage
there was no record of the incident is
what he said on Twitter but I would
think that Jake after making that
allegation and then banks makes a video
saying like somebody from Team 10
drugged him that they were there trying
to get him drunk and that this whole
thing was orchestrated as some thing - I
don't know [ __ ] with him which seems
pretty out-there the whole thing seems
so out there yeah at that point it's
just like the whole story's it's just
ridiculous
leave me out of this yeah but the one
thing is that Jake makes this video
being like you choked out my assistant
and I'm gonna go get the security
footage and you know he hasn't really
had any
Stan show response and according to
banks the security footage shows no
incident well apparently they reported
it to the police right so anyway that's
it that's all I want to say about it so
you know not yeah do not get involved
for anyone thought that we did take his
side we're not taking yeah definitely
not I'm just hearing Jake out because
it's he's sitting here I'm listening to
his side of the story anyway that's me
that's that's my take on that whole
thing but it's way too way too spicy to
get involved in it's linked own YouTube
channel to the extreme YouTube drama
Chris Brown edition hmm I love hitting
on Chris Brown he's so hateable he looks
like a he how is that guy still popular
man I don't know I guess that's a
separate conversation yeah all right
fair enough
so scre le as we we talked about him
friend of the show
everybody's a friend of the show now and
frankly I've lost all respect yeah
so I got some excerpts from the jurors
on scre Ali's case so they're so how it
works when somebody goes to a trial is
that they interview jurors randomly from
the populace in that area to sit on the
jury to make a judgement call on this
guy after witnessing the trial and they
ask them a bunch of questions to see if
they're biased because you want a juror
who's not biased who's fit to serve and
can think rationally and fairly about
the case yeah so they bring in people
and they ask him a bunch of questions
and based on their answers they'll
either select them or you know send them
away
or relieve them of their duty right so I
got some excerpts of the lawyer asking
these jurors what they think about
shkreli and they're actually quite quite
spicy here let's hear the so here's one
the court says the purpose of jury
selection is to ensure fairness and
impartiality in this case if you think
that you could be fair and impartial it
is your duty to tell me if you could not
be fair it is your duty to tell me all
right
juror number one I'm aware of the
defendant and I hate him
they says I'm sorry I think he's a
greedy little man damn I guess you're
excused
although it's way more admirable to just
say that honestly than to be like oh I
don't know him while holding a grudge
and then obstructing justice
yeah juror number 59 your honor totally
he's guilty and in no way can I let him
slide out of anything okay is that your
attitude towards anyone charged with a
crime who has not been proven guilty
it's my added toward towards his whole
demeanor and what he's done to people
all right we're going to excuse you sir
and then he follows up with and he
disrespected the wu-tang clan probably
played that in his head I love that and
on his way out he disrespected the
wu-tang is that the blue tang or is that
the whatever sign I think that's what is
that it no there's more than one the
question is have you heard anything that
would affect your ability in this case
to be open-minded I don't think I can be
because he looks like kind of a dick
you're juror number 144 and we will
excuse you well if you ever want to get
a jury duty fresh tips from Martins
Corelli's case anyway
pretty pretty sassy is there more I
think that's it yeah yeah and then
finally or yeah I mean yeah this is
finally so once again I got a lot of
disrespect for talking about Ilan to I
people have lost all respect for me hmm
yeah he lawns okay but Ethan's lack of
research made me lose all respect from
Elon Musk who I still love and who's an
angel
I'm gonna put them in the thumbnail with
a halo and a glow around his silhouette
do you understand
I don't care about your respect I just
want you no one's dick in my mouth
so Elon Musk is leading a collective of
a hundred and sixteen experts calling
for an outright ban on killer robots
weaponized robots open letter signed by
Tesla chief and Google's
must CEO um urges the you want to block
use of lethal might on the screen so we
can oh yeah open that's some high level
[ __ ] you uh so yeah so essentially
what's going on this is not really so
much about like artificial intelligence
as it is well I guess it is it's
weaponizing like advanced computers and
Nai
and they're basically saying on this
article this collective that we need to
regulate this [ __ ] before we usher in a
third wave of weaponized combat mm-hmm
was like first you had like modern
warfare
then you had nuclear bombs and they're
saying that this third wave of AI
machine fueled warfare is gonna is gonna
be even worse than all those that's
pretty scary like they says that Dan you
have some of those quotes about what
they said well they say once to hear
once developed lethal autonomous weapons
will permit armed conflict to be fought
on a scale greater than ever at
timescales faster than humans can
comprehend that's the crazy thing about
AI where it's like you don't even
understand what they're doing until the
whole [ __ ] world they're playing a
chess game essentially with massacres
and we're a that's right I mean so
flattered idle after all the years these
can be weapons of terror weapons of
death spits and terrorists use against
innocent populations and weapons hack to
behave
undesirable ways we don't have long to
act once this Pandora's Box is open it
will be hard to close experts have
previously warned the AI technology has
reached a point where development of
autonomous weapons is feasible within
years so this is pretty scary stuff
[ __ ] you're seeing movies it's happening
okay I'm telling you listen in about
everything listen to you on about
everything I've lost all respect for you
Ethan
I'm kidding I'm [ __ ] kidding anything
about wasn't chill out let's all respect
for myself so here eh so nor are South
Korea is already using fully autonomous
like AI weapons on the border great
demilitarized zone I love this called
the deminer mineralized zone militarized
zone it's got like the most advanced
weapons on earth look at this [ __ ] this
is a fully autonomous robotic sentry gun
on the border of North Korea's South
Korea missionary had a [ __ ] Robocop
this thing has like infrared heat
tracking night-vision it has like
basically every component of of weaponry
to it and and it's fully autonomous it
can track people walking like from a
mile away just by their heat that is
pretty pretty scary this is straight at
a fallout right like you know Dark
Brotherhood [ __ ] look at this thing yeah
so this is what's going on this is just
the beginning you know imagine the drone
with one of these strapped to the mat or
a submarine these already exist there's
a there's a USS warship that is unmanned
out on the ocean right now built in 2016
completely unmanned oh really yeah so
these instruments of war I mean it's
cool there's two sides to it right you
take out the human component and nobody
gets hurt but when you take out the
human component you also lose all
compassion you lose all perception of
what war really is mm-hmm when you have
a [ __ ] like there's this classic
story during the Cold War there was a
Russian sub armed with nuclear warheads
and they got a false alarm in the
submarine that the United States had
nuked Russia and their instruments have
malfunction and it was telling them to
launch nukes at the United States and
this one guy in that submarine what he
was like I'm not doing it
this doesn't make sense I'm not doing it
even though the orders were to shoot it
Wow and but that human compassion that
human touch that human life down there
was basically prevented a nuclear
holocaust and if you know this thing's
run by by computers you don't have that
filter so what is it that um Elon Musk
is doing right now so basically he's
he's leading a coalition of experts
petitioning governments to and the UN to
block the use of lethal autonomous
weapons so they're there they're talking
to governments governing bodies saying
let's not go down this path but sadly I
think it's too late I don't think
there's any way to stop it maybe I'm
wrong but it's like inevitable I mean
war is always and so it there's always
an arms race that's that's how power is
expressed and today you know the United
States China Russia it's [ __ ] it's an
arms race always this whole thing with
AI I wasn't even thinking about it until
you know Musk tweeted about it I know
that's what I'm saying but frankly I've
lost all respect for you for even
acknowledging it that's the issue anyway
I don't have anything alighting to like
to uh to end on but I want to say thank
you everybody for watching thicker one
who supports us through subscriptions
here on Twitch through Amazon Prime
twitch donations everybody thank you so
much god bless you next week our shard
this week our next episode is memories
gonna be on Thursday at 3:00 we're not
doing it on Friday this week and it's
gonna be a lot of fun I'm having Ryan
Jones amiss and Skippy
dating advice collins probably probably
not confirmed while Skippy's in Ryan's
in I mean he's not in officially but
he's in let me check my phone email he
may well have answer already no not yet
and we do want to call out for graphic
designers right oh yeah wait the Streamy
Awards answered halong so according to
the sky from the streamys the winners
are determined by the streamys
blue-ribbon panel a judge body of
creators executives and other
professionals in the online industry
there are two fan-voted categories to
show of the year and creator of the year
so there's only two fan voted huh so
that's it so that's the one that fuzzy
those are the two he won alright this
creator of the year I think that's so
funny because last year fousey likes
weeped this the streamys and he was
doing all this [ __ ] just begging begging
begging tweeting and he even like set up
a giveaway where you would only be
entered by voting for him on the
streamys and I think so I bet he's one
of the two categories so that's that's
that's better that's cool you're
drinking from it's a double cup
situation trying to minimize always yeah
we're looking for a designer to do we
have the email setup then yes we do what
is it it is going on the screen right
now it is graphics age three age three
at gmail.com is it on the screen they
can see it yep so we are basically
looking to start up our own merch
operation between here the podcast and
h3h3 productions we're looking for a
talented designer who is familiar with
our content and also very expert in
illustrator yeah illustrator we're
looking for a serious designer someone
we can work with and chill with and be
[ __ ] have a cool times the reason is
for merch so especially if you have any
experience we're doing merge that would
be beneficial so please send your your
CV or resume or you can just even say hi
here's my portfolio link to tumblr or
whatever you have
but please don't apply if you don't have
experience in illustrator that yeah that
is required for the job because that's
how you export the image and send it to
the to the shirt people so anyway thanks
for watching guys had a lot of fun here
on the Tuesday therapy episode and we'll
see you on Thursday for next week for
the next episode this week so thank you
all so much for coming along and we'll
see you in a couple of days guys
appreciate you thanks da
[Music]